not only do we have no idea how the
ancient Egyptians actually constructed
the pyramids but we have no feasible
clue how they lifted Stones as heavy as
1,000 tons 2 million pound and then
inexplicably transported them hundreds
of miles make no mistake it is a fact
that the Egyptians left us with no
explanation for how they move stones of
that magnitude hundreds of miles and
then lifted and stack them hundreds of
feet above the ground and in this video
I'm going to start off by sharing a few
fascinating details that will primer
your brain and by the end of this video
very likely blow your mind so let me
start off by mentioning that the largest
and heaviest stone blocks in the Great
Pyramid of Giza are 70 to 80 ton Rose
Granite stones that originate from the
Aswan querry which is more than 800 kilm
or some 500 miles away and hundreds of
these blocks were utilized within the
grand gallery and the so-called King's
chamber as well as the enormous relief
columns that stand above it which extend
hundreds of feet above ground level to
put this enormous undertaking into
perspective 80 tons is significantly
heavier than a modern Abrams tank which
in itself is extremely heavy but what's
Wild is that these 80 ton stones are
mere Child's Play in comparison to other
little known Stones the Egyptians cut
carved moved and lifted for example the
colasse of mnan located in Luxor
absolutely dwarfs the largest stones of
the Great Pyramid in fact they are
closer to 10 times as heavy weighing in
at a staggering
720 tons a piece and not only that they
were carved from one single piece of
stone which is incredible when you
consider that the seated statues stand
over 60 ft or 18 m in height so large
that you can only properly appreciate
their Eminence when compared to people
even the pedestals these two statues
stand upon are enormous weighing in the
realm of hundreds of tons in fact so
heavy that half of them are now
submerged within the Earth Egyptian
Antiquity authorities no longer allow
anyone to touch these statues so it's
difficult to find any recent highquality
photos for comparison however I found a
few that were taken during some
restoration efforts a number of years
ago notice that this man isn't even half
the size of this statue's lower leg and
here's another showing an adult man that
is barely taller than the ankle and by
the way you can clearly see that the
statue on the right was heavily damaged
and restored as you can see from its now
blocky configuration but make no mistake
it is documented that both of these
statues were indeed carved from one
piece of stone which is obviously
apparent when you look at the statue on
the left but if the size and weight of
these statues isn't interesting enough
when you learn that they originate from
a quy near Cairo which is nearly 400
miles away by Road or just over 300
miles away in a totally straight line as
the bird flies we have to ask ourselves
how on Earth did the the ancient Smo
stones of this magnitude and over such a
vast distance now this is the part of
the video where things get very
interesting because although the colossi
of mnon statues are closer to 10 times
as heavy as the largest Stones within
the Great Pyramid they are not even
close to the largest statues created by
the Egyptians what you're seeing here
are the remnants of the ramum which is
one of the largest stone monoliths ever
cut carved transported and placed in
human history this Behemoth was shaped
from one solid piece of granite Stone
and is estimated to have weighed 1,000
tons or some 2 million PB that's the
weight of approximately 15 Abrams tanks
and get this it was somehow transported
at least 115 mil from the Aswan query
this is in the realm of exceeding what
we are even capable of doing today as
you will see for yourself in just a
moment but let me first ask the question
which is what on Earth destroyed it and
into so many pieces this was was a
seated statue and it's hard to imagine
that even an earthquake would have
knocked it over I mean if it were a
standing statue toppling over and
breaking apart would not be hard to
imagine but having been seated it
boggles the mind to comprehend what type
of forces would have been involved to
not only knock it over but for it to
break apart with this level of
Devastation and just look at how large
various aspects of it are the top of the
foot is up to my belly button and I'm 5'
10 or 178 cm and this statue is so large
that it's difficult to capture a good
photo of it especially one that shows
you just how insanely large it actually
is pictures do not do it justice for
what your eyes witness in person and you
might also find it curious to know that
this statue was the inspiration for the
famous azy mandus poem which describes
the mysterious discovery of a stone
statue in the Egyptian desert and on the
pedestal it read my name is Azie mandas
King of Kings look upon my works ye
Mighty and despair that's epic and by
the way oim mandus is the ancient Greek
word for the name ramsy II who this
statue is said to be of now when I said
that this is in the realm of exceeding
what we're even capable of doing today
let me share some fascinating details
with you that will paint all of us a
picture for just how spectacular and
mysterious The Works of the ancient
Egyptians actually is what you're seeing
here is the largest Ultra class Hull
truck ever created the bellaz 75710 is
sheer Marvel of engineering so large
that you must travel up two flights of
stairs to reach the cockpit in fact the
tires themselves are 13 and 1/4 ft in
diameter that's virtually equivalent to
the largest African bull elephants each
tire weighs more than 5 tons or 10,000
lb and get this cost
$60,000 a piece and this truck has eight
of them now this is where things get
wild as this 16 cylinder diesel truck
produces four 4,600 horsepower and has
the highest payload capacity on Earth
achieving a Max load of
496 tons that means it could carry
approximately eight Abrams Tanks if they
could actually fit in it now as
unbelievably impressive as that is let
us focus on the astonishing fact that
the statue at the ramum is quite
literally double the weight capacity of
this truck this in itself calls the very
laws of physics into question and that
it raises the prospect that the Ancients
must surely have possessed some type of
lost technology that we are unaware of
to have accomplished what they did and
if you have any doubts about that what
I'm going to show you now should be the
proverbial nail in the coffin to prove
this point in 2012 the Los Angeles
County Museum of Art took up a project
called levitated Mass where they chose
to create a large-scale public art
sculpture that consisted of a 340 ton
Granite stone that would appear to be
levitating in front of the museum this
680,000 lb stone is 21 ft tall and was
transported 106 mi from the Quarry and
this is where it gets amazing as this
340 ton Stone had to have a custom
trailer truck constructed around it and
get this the trailer was 260 ft long 32
ft wide had 44 axles and
196 semi- Wheels we've of course all
heard of 18 wheelers well this thing has
11 times as many tires and to move this
Stone 106 miles it traveled 4 M an hour
took 11 nights and costed a whopping $10
million in fact this project was said to
be quote the largest operation of its
kind since the Egyptians built the
pyramids and it took a year of planning
a preparation to complete it from start
to finish so let me get this straight
this 340 ton stone is well under half
the weight of the two colasse of M9
statues that removed more than three
times the distance and this 340 ton
stone is virtually 1third the weight of
the 1,00 ton ramum statue which was
moved even further than this one see
this is what I'm getting at we have
absolutely no clue how the Ancients move
stones of this magnitude and to be clear
I am not saying that the dynastic
Egyptians didn't move stones of course
they did in fact there's a depiction of
a statue being dragged on wood sleds by
workmen but that statue was oneir the
height of all the others at 22 ft and
weighed 64 tons thus a micro fraction of
the weight that the various statues
discussed in this video are and just as
importantly to mention was moved over a
very short distance make no mistake the
dynastic Egyptians that we are aware of
accomplished impressive Feats but I do
not think for a second that wood sleds
could possibly support 2 million pounds
without being totally crushed and
obliterated and not to mention pushed
into the Earth along with it and never
mind how on Earth they would would have
even lifted the stones on top of them I
mean we're talking about 15 times the
weight of this one example I should also
mention that modern academics theorize
that surely the Ancients would have
utilized the Nile River to transport
various Stones rather than
Overland however the reality is that
there is zero evidence that the ancient
Egyptians possessed any vessel that was
even remotely capable of transporting
720 tons much less 1,000 tons and this
isn't even taking into account this she
physics that would be at play when
lifting that type of weight on and off
the boat in fact if you take it upon
yourself to research known Egyptian
vessels of that era it's abundantly
clear that stones of this magnitude were
not transported on the Nile with the
known capabilities of the dynastic
Egyptians that we were all taught about
in school and that's not to say that the
Egyptians didn't move smaller stone
blocks on the Nile by boat this is
documented for example the notable Diary
of merror describes a receipt for
Limestone blocks that were brought to
Giza by boat however it's already known
that millions of small Limestone blocks
make up the hundreds of mastabas and
various structures that surround the
pyramids again these blocks are another
micr fraction compared to the 80 ton
Stones inside the Great Pyramid so
there's no comparison here and besides
all that the torei mentioned in the
diarrhea miror where those smaller
Stones originate from is only 8 and 1
half miles from Giza and by the way
while I'm at it it's also worth
mentioning that in the case of two
colossi of mnon statues originating from
uh Cairo if they had been moved by some
primitive barge they would have had to
fight the current as the Nile river
flows from south to North and again
luxer is more than 300 miles south of
Cairo like I always say look and think
for yourself do you really think that
Legions of half- naked Barefoot men
rolled 1,000 ton Stones hundreds of
miles or are these nothing more than an
academic textbook illustration based on
nothing more more than theoretical
fiction now real quick to paint us a
picture of the kind of magnitude that
we're dealing with here here is a short
montage video showing a bunch of modern
fails where people try to lift and move
stones that are a fraction of the weight
of the ones that we're talking about in
this video and look at how this
[Music]
goes
a
[Music]
how do you like that choice of music now
obviously those people messed up and
didn't use equipment correctly or did
not use the correct equipment at all and
I'm not saying we can't lift massive
Stones today or thousand ton Stones yes
we can but this illustrates the point
that I'm trying to make of just how
insane of a project this was for the
Ancients when they didn't possess the
type of technology that we do today now
to wrap this up let me read to you the
full aimus poem as I think you'll find
it to be quite
awesome I met a traveler from an antique
land who said two vast and trunkless
legs of Stone Stand in the desert near
them on the sand half sunk a shattered
Visage lies whose frowned and wrinkled
lip and sneer of cold command tell that
it sculptor well those passions read
which yet surviv stamped on those
lifeless things the hand that mocked
them and the heart that fed and on the
pedestal these words appear my name is
azy mandus King of Kings look on my
Works ye Mighty and despair nothing
beside remains round the decay of that
colossal wreck boundless and be the lone
and level stands stretch far
away I have to say I like that poem my
name is Jimmy corsetti my channel is
called bright Insight hit the like
button and subscribe and leave a comment
sharing your thoughts on everything that
was discussed in this video that said
I'll close it up here take care
everybody